hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
for recently we saw the warcraft movie
bomb in the u.s. box office however it
was a massive hit in China Princeton and
Riot Games have said that they're open
to the idea of having a league of
legends we debate which is why we've
decided to count down the top 10
champions that you'd like to see in the
movie and the actors that should play
them coming in at number 10 is Michael B
Jordan as Lucian we think he'd look
great in a heartseeker Lucian costume
our ninth spot goes to brie Larson as
Leona in addition to being an active
chameleon and winning an Academy Award
she is the embodiment of a strong woman
I appreciate it thank you grabbing the
eighth spot is Emma Roberts as jinx jinx
is the ultimate badass small looks super
powerful and so is Emma Robert we think
she'd kill it as jinx
[Music]
coming in seventh is Donald Glover as
echo if Donald Glover aka childish
gambino could take some time out of its
hit show Atlanta to take on the role as
echo we'd be super excited
Glover would be perfect at the boy who
shattered time
[Music]
coming in six is Channing Tatum as Garen
he was the hunk in Magic Mike and well
he'll be the hunk in our fantasy league
movie as well grabbing the fifth spot on
our list is gal gadot asked averse gal
gadot is Wonder Woman and luckily for
her Sivir has a Wonder Woman inspired
skin talk about a match made in heaven
stealing the fourth spot is emilia
clarke as the famous ash we think her
role on Game of Thrones would transition
perfectly into playing ash in a league
movie she has the experience the look
and the acting chops my reign is just
begun our third spot goes to Hugh
Jackman as grave I mean grace kind of
looks like Hugh Jackman already so it
could be a very easy transition Plus
have you seen his fighting abilities
coming in second is Scarlett Johansson
as Miss Fortune she's used to playing an
action hero from all the Marvel movies
she starred in and she definitely looks
the part our number one spot goes to the
legendary Dwayne the rock Johnson as
Darius there really isn't anyone as
fitting as the rock to play a champion
as large as Darius and hey if you want
to sell a lot of movie tickets then
Dwayne Johnson has to be in a starring
role ah what the rock is cooking so
those were our picks for the movie is
there a champion or after that you'd
like to see let us know in the comments
below
thanks for watching
if you want more great content be sure
to hit that subscribe button